[Music]
okay welcome back everybody uh sorry
about that we had some technical issues
but uh if you're just joining i am
talking about uh this crazy opening that
just got played at the tata steel chest
tournament between shock mom and darv
and andre asipenco so let's just jump
into it we've got d4
knight f6 c4 e6 and as i was saying this
is uh probably the most common position
after one d4 that you're going to get
from here white does a number of
different
lines or different ideas all of which
are totally fine the most common of
which are you know knight c3 or knight
f3
and then you get into queen's gambit
decline type structures so i'm sure you
guys probably seen something like this
before in your own games
what you probably haven't seen is the
move that shock mom and yara played in
this game
so i'm sure some of you guys at watching
from home have seen this play did you
guys uh catch this game have you been
following any of the professional
tournaments okay
so shock played the shocking
g4 in this position so what on earth is
going on here uh this you know this
doesn't seem to make any sense we're
playing in the center we're developing
our pieces and then all of a sudden uh
the move g4 comes out uh to everybody's
surprise andre esapenko especially
looked very very shocked when this move
happened
um
so of course uh what is what is going on
here what move jumps out to you after
you see g4 on the board
yeah the knight attacks it so so what's
going on why doesn't black just capture
this pawn what could white's idea be
okay so we could attack this knight with
uh bishop h3
um
yeah so no this is one option let's
let's generate some more ideas see we
can come up with
yeah so pawn e4 it is and i think this
is also a good idea um basically
whenever uh you sacrifice a pawn in the
opening like this generally the
compensation happens because it takes
your opponent time to capture this pawn
so for example rather than develop a
piece or control the center
with black's next move he would have
spent a turn capturing the pawn
and then after e4 which i think is the
most useful move we are again attacking
this knight and black is going to have
to spend another turn
uh either defending this knight or
moving this knight and for example after
maybe a bad line like knight f6
something like e5 could happen and white
would be expanding in the center getting
all kinds of space and this knight would
actually be quite close to to entirely
trapped like it doesn't have very many
squares that it can go to now obviously
black can do other things after e4 but
that's the idea
white is trying to make black lose some
time by capturing this pawn on g4 and
he's going to use that time
to
try and take over the center try and get
a lead in development try and uh get
some other kind of advantage for the
pawn
uh now in the game uh esepenco actually
did not take on g4 so we're going to
start with that we're going to start
with the game and then sort of circle
back and and see what's going on in all
these variations
uh but first i want to ask you guys if
you've ever seen a similar idea to this
and this is for the viewers at home as
well uh g4
now i had never seen it in this position
and in fact it really hasn't been played
by
titled players
over the board ever
but a similar idea has been tried so
does anybody know what i'm talking about
has anybody seen this before
no okay that's totally fine
if i mention the name
simon williams some people at home might
have uh
might have an idea
and someone in the chat says they've
played a
uh local player jacob sanders who often
plays the grub but not talking about the
grub
um
and yeah it looks like the chat is also
unfamiliar so i'll go ahead and show it
um rather than c4 e6 and then g4
uh actually uh sort of amazingly two g4
has been played numerous times before uh
by some even some strong players
and uh with very very mixed results this
move is also slightly dubious
so i wanted to first look at this move
to try and understand why shock came up
with with g4 and move three so we're
going to take a look at some some games
from this position as well notably the
ginger gm simon williams is famous for
playing this in a few different games
but
against this line for example we'll see
that after knight takes g4 again e4 is
the idea in this position black has this
move d5 both countering in the center
and defending the knight and perhaps
this is the heart of why uh shakum and
yara have decided he would throw in c4
e6 and then look at g4 because now in
similar lines this idea of playing d5 or
d6
moving the d pawn controlling the center
and defending the knight simply doesn't
work because of course
this pawn in on e6 is actually working
against black in this instance
um so just some some food for thought
there on where shock might have been
coming from
uh but you have to put yourself in andre
esopenco's shoes you know you're
you're playing shock mom and yara chess
legend uh top 10 player forever and he
plays g4 against you on move three uh do
you really want to be the hero that
captures this pawn and walks into
whatever preparation shock has so essie
pango decided he didn't want to be a
hero today and so he just plays d5
and i think this is really a nice
concept for for you guys if
you're playing against somebody and they
play just something absolutely crazy in
the opening uh some crazy idea like g4
that you've never seen before you are by
no means obligated to accept their their
crazy sacrifice their crazy gambit
you can always just fall back on basic
principles uh d5 is always going to be a
good move it controls the center it
helps you
in development it activates or it gives
you this square for your pieces even
your bishop and
now black is going to have a very
comfortable time just continuing with
development and playing normal chess
which is always a great option if you're
uncomfortable in the opening
uh so now
the question comes back to to white what
is the the point of our opening right uh
if you play g4 and your opponent doesn't
take it why do you have your g pawn on
g4 so let's see see if you guys can
uncover uh shock's idea what move is he
going to try to play next
what do you think he had in mind if
black does not capture the pawn
yeah exactly pawn to g5 is is going to
be the move here and this was the point
of g4
white was hoping to interfere with
black's regular development by by
kicking this knight around a little bit
uh so now the question comes back to
estipenko uh where do you want to put
this knight
uh so we've been challenged in the
center what's the most natural square
for the knight to jump to
what makes sense here
d7
yes so so ben says knight back to d7
which is a pretty reasonable option you
know we've made this square uh by
playing d5
uh and if you uh
wanted to be super safe maybe you would
play play knight to d7 but we actually
do have a better move in this instance
sorry what was that
yeah knight e4 and this is actually just
going to be a very very strong move uh
so
white now has a number of problems uh
number one our g pawn is attacked which
we've already seen maybe we don't care
the most about but number two this
knight is going to be a very very active
piece here on on e4 and we'll see that
that makes uh white make a pretty big
concession on the next turn
so
white now continues with development
with bishop g2 uh but what would happen
again if we we tried some move like h4
what do you think black's idea is going
to be
black can immediately get a pretty
pretty big advantage here
yeah thanks to this knight on e4 moves
like bishop b4 check are going to be
very annoying for white to deal with you
cannot play the natural
immediately you get captured and this is
probably a tactic you're familiar with
uh and if you try something like bishop
to d2 white might just capture this
and after captures take on c4 for
example and with this knight pinned uh
black's queen is going to be invading
and you have all kinds of problems uh
not the least of which is you've just
just lost a pawn on c4 turns out the
queen's gambit sometimes it is an actual
gambit and black takes your pawn if you
do
stuff that's a little bit too crazy
so uh black is already you know sort of
putting the test to white he says yeah
i'm gonna punish you for not playing
knight c3 and playing stupid g4 g5 stuff
instead uh and the way i'm gonna punish
that is by activating my pieces i have a
strong knight in the center because you
didn't contest that square i'm
threatening to bring out my other pieces
with tempo and just get uh a good
opening advantage based on opening
principles and that's sort of the lesson
i want to take away from from this game
is
uh against you know insane maniacs with
their crazy opening gambits good
principal chess is usually going to be
enough to get you uh
in an okay position at least in this
case a pretty good position
but shock you know obviously had some
deeper ideas in mind he came up with
this move bishop to g2
and then after bishop b4 check
what on earth could shock have been
thinking about here
because we just talked about why these
moves are bad and even this move is bad
so what is what is the point after
bishop g bishop to b4 check
that's actually right um very
surprisingly white willingly willingly
moves the king away with king to f1 and
this is the line that was played in the
game
um so having the king on f1
maybe not ideal but if you haven't
noticed white's pawn is on g5 so
castling king's side was already sort of
sort of a long shot so
in some openings like this you'll
actually find that the king sometimes
rarely belongs on f1 sometimes even f2
can be a home for the king and in this
case king f1 is about the best place on
the board for this king to be you don't
really want to castle queen side because
you've played d4 and c4 don't really
want to castle king's side because you
put your pawn on g5 so it turns out king
f1 not such a bad idea after all
now once again black could consider
taking this pawn on g5
but for the exact same reasons as before
maybe this is not what uh escipanko is
is looking to do
it's going to allow white to have some
pressure in the center stuff like queen
b3 is going to be coming out as well
attacking the bishop and the central
pawns and uh it's going to be
sacrificing time to take the pawn
so instead uh essie penko does the very
very natural bishop back to e7
rather than take this with the knight
which leaves the knight in very awkward
in a very awkward spot
black would much rather take with the
bishop
threatening to simplify things and even
activate the queen against white's now
slightly weakened king
shock of course is not going to let that
happen so he plays the move h4 just
defending the pawn
and now simply castles king's side by
esipenko
so even though shock has played some of
the most ridiculous moves i've ever seen
in the opening black has kept things
solid and kept things very very standard
i mean if you ignore the white pawns on
g5 and h4 i'm sure this looks very
normal right we just developed our
bishop to e7 we castled king's side we
have the same pawn structure that we
would have in a normal opening
and again that's kind of the point essie
panko just playing normal chess and and
doing fine
uh knight h3 is how shock is developing
the pieces now uh he chooses h3 uh
because it is important still to defend
g5 and rather than knight f3 which might
look more natural controlling the center
uh knight h3 is chosen i think because
we need some of this pressure against
this knight on e4 it's preventing black
from playing things like d take c4
and now black is just always going to
have to be slightly worried that we
might capture this knight
black continues out with c6 just uh
solidifying his position a little bit
more totally fine
and now we get this move queen to c2
and it turns out that with how the
opening had gone uh the position should
be more or less equal here which makes
sense right uh white did some crazy
crazy stuff black just played normal
moves uh black didn't try to refute the
opening by taking the the free pawn uh
and so both sides are just doing fine
black hasn't really made any huge uh
mistakes against you know the laws of
chess he's developed his pieces castled
as king so how can you be much worse
meanwhile white has done some crazy
stuff but he has the benefit of moving
first so he might have lost his first
move advantage but not too much beyond
that
but after queen to c2 it does turn out
that black can start to take the
advantage
and we'll see why in a moment so what
should white have done instead well it
turns out that it is actually time to
take this knight on e4
and then just develop out and play for
pressure against the slightly weakened
pawn and black here is is still going to
be doing fine uh because of you know
first of all white's king
and secondly
uh some pressure against white's center
as well moves like c5 are going to be
important even ideas like e5 and black
is going to have plenty of active
counter play
but instead of that after queen to c2
which move do you think
maintains the advantage for black black
has a really nice option here
so of course white is
kind of making a threat here we're
really putting pressure against this
knight
any ideas
so we don't have to overcomplicate it uh
what do you normally do when
someone attacks your pieces more times
than they're defended like you have a
few options you can move them away or
you can defend them again so what what
kind of moves
do that for black here
so f5 is one option and that seems to be
what actually the chatroom online is
talking about here um but that one looks
looks a little wild so what is the the
simple move quote unquote
moving back right yeah uh so where would
we move the knight back
yeah d6 so
uh what what is the the benefit to this
move well it it turns out that uh
this pressure against the c4 pawn
turns out to be really important uh now
if you've played much uh
queen's gambit and type ideas with the
white pieces you'll know that oftentimes
you don't really want to capture this
pawn
now why is that what does capturing this
pawn allow black to do in many instances
yeah free up their pieces specifically
this bishop on c8 is the one to look at
so right now this bishop on c8 doesn't
really have anywhere to go it's trapped
behind the pawn chain and in order to
fully equalize in normal queen's game of
positions uh you have to work a little
bit harder to get this bishop active
sometimes you go b6 bishop b7 and c5 or
something
sometimes white does end up taking on d5
but the point is that's basically
black's last remaining big problem in in
this position black hasn't made any
weaknesses uh black just needs to find
some way to finish development by
bringing this bishop out so with knight
d6 black is very much hoping for the
move c takes d5 after which we would
play e takes d5 and in order to give
this bishop this nice f5 square uh
notably also coming with tempo against
the queen supported by the knight so
knight d6 turns out to be a really nice
idea because number one
it resolves the threat against the
knight number two it puts pressure on
the c4 pawn kind of inducing this move
uh pawn takes c4
now white wouldn't have to uh take
necessarily knight d2 as possible but
after that we're going to see that black
does have pretty meaningful pressure
against this pawn something like knight
a6
and if h5 for example trying to continue
the attack just as an example line we
could take on c4 we could also go knight
b4
and start doing some some really crazy
stuff here late like a5 and it turns out
that this pressure on the queen side is
going to give black quite a lot of
counter play for example a3 we can even
play this crazy idea d take c4
and so what's the tactic here why aren't
we losing a knight well if you take
believe it or not after takes back we
have two pretty major threats and white
would be be losing tactically so
really crazy stuff going on uh but it's
not shocking that black has tactics here
uh forgive the accidental pun that time
it was accidental um it's not shocking
that black has
tactics here because
of course white's pieces look like this
you know
and that's another thing to sort of take
take to heart whenever you don't follow
opening principles whenever you play
sort of anti-strategic moves that that
are complicated and tactical oftentimes
your opponent is going to have more
opportunities than they otherwise would
have because this rook on a1 is
undefended because this bishop is
interfering with
white strokes getting connected all of a
sudden there's a tactic because this
rook just isn't defended and and white
needs to
deal with these problems
uh so tactics come from loose pieces
something to keep in mind
now in the game uh scpenko actually
chose none of the above so
f5 maybe you can get away with this move
but uh it definitely wouldn't be
wouldn't be my first choice here notably
this is always going to going to weaken
the e6 pawn quite a bit that might not
be something you're interested in doing
especially with this knight uh jumping
into f4 in many instances it just gives
up a lot of these dark squares that that
white is uh
really fighting for right you know he
wants the f4 square he wants all of
these dark squares and he wants black to
to weaken these squares
so f5 not my favorite
instead
essie penco did the third thing that you
can do whenever your opponent makes a
threat so rather than respond to the
threat by moving away or defending you
can create a counter threat or basically
ignore your opponent do something else
that you consider to be more important
so what could esiepenko have possibly
had in mind
what could he possibly think about doing
remember black's remaining problems this
bishop on c8 we have to get it developed
somehow um and i can also sort of
include this knight as well as sort of
being a problem we want to find some way
to finish activating our pieces
these squares
yeah so maybe b6 is an okay move here
but it's not quite severe enough it
turns out that you know white white was
making a real threat here and you might
end up
regretting giving up this pawn so easily
so something even more severe than than
b6 but you're on the right track trying
to solve this bishop
solve your problems
what was that
yeah that's that's exactly right uh
andre acepenko came up with this crazy
idea pawn to e5 and so
what on earth is is going on here well
uh for one asipenco is sort of taking
advantage of the fact of chess that you
can only take one piece at a time
um
meaning that if you take this pawn on e5
then you haven't captured this knight on
e4 and so now black has time to play
move like bishop f5 both defending this
knight and creating threats of moves
like knight g3 with an attack against
the king and the queen
and in these these kinds of lines black
is just getting a lot of threats and a
lot of tempo and black should be sort of
doing very very well here
and of course the idea is that if you
take on e4 then you haven't taken on e5
for example
and again
black is is going to be able to
activate using this this extra time that
you've spent capturing uh capturing
these pawns something like queen d4 for
example might be very strong
instead of all of those options uh shock
actually just increases the pressure
with this move knight to d2
uh which i i think is is a good idea uh
keeping the tension here and sort of
asking black to to figure it out for
himself now so black does decide it's
time to simplify and takes on d2 white
takes on d2 uh black takes on d4 taking
advantage of this pawn on e5 and in
response white takes on d5
black takes on d5 and then we see this
move knight f4 so the the smoke is sort
of cleared here uh the the tension in
the center has been resolved technically
black won a pawn but you'll notice that
these pawns are doubled and very very
likely one of these pawns is going to
end up falling
and to that effect shock now plays
knight f4
attacking the d5 pawn
now what did black get uh with all of
these ideas well he's he's opened up
this diagonal for the bishop and he
immediately makes use of that by playing
this move bishop to e6
uh and now here again the game has once
again sort of fallen into a balance
black didn't play this knight d6 idea
which would have been really strong
instead came kind of came up with this
complicated line with e5 uh but white
once again is is going to be doing okay
here and it's not too difficult to
understand why he he has activated all
of his minor pieces uh they're actually
serving sort of a cohesive purpose this
bishop defends the knight bishop the
knight worked together in the center
and now all shock needed to do is sort
of stick with this flow continue
activating his remaining pieces play
something like queen b3 increase the
pressure against these pawns play
something like rook c1
uh maybe try to fix his king's position
a little bit more place it on a square
like g2 i think any of these ideas would
have been pretty okay for white
but instead he found a very tempting
looking move but it turns out this move
is just going to be a mistake i think
definitely what he should have done
something like queen b3 and just attack
these guys keep the threats coming and
we might have seen something like queen
to d7
defending here after which things might
might have simplified a little bit
uh something like this knight c6 for
example and we're just gonna have a
pretty level position white gets the
pawn back
but black finished finishes development
and can control some of the central
squares
instead of that
see if you can find a very very tricky
idea that shock came up with here
and it's it's an idea worth looking at
because uh oftentimes it is going to be
a very very strong move it just turns
out it's not the idea in this instance
so
very tempting idea very strong idea
that's uh uh really tries to to ruin
black's king's side structure
what could he have in mind
yeah so
this is a hugely important um
feature of the position is we we have
this pressure on e6
and it is sort of tempting to actually
capture this bishop when after f takes
you'll notice that black's control over
these light squares has start started to
weaken a little bit right we're missing
this f pawn defending these light
squares
but it turns out if we capture on e6
it's really difficult to increase the
pressure any further you know it's it's
tough to find the next move maybe like
bishop h3 or something
but black can pretty handily deal with
this threat something like queen to d6
um defending the pawn and it's tough to
get the rest of our pieces involved
and in fact things like queen to g3
might might start looking a little bit
scary for for white as well
so knight to e6 we have this sort of
latency pressure on the light squares
but maybe there is another way to go
about threatening those light squares
and someone from the chat does have the
right idea
so what else can we do to soften up the
this light squared complex
around the black king
all right any ideas before i give it
away
okay so as some people in the chat are
saying
rather than something like knight takes
e6 and following it up with something
like g6 when black could move out of the
way and keep things locked down
it might not be a bad idea to actually
play this counter-intuitive move g6
right away uh and at first glance this
looks sort of suicidal this pawn is
attacked a billion times by by two other
pawns
but it turns out black has no good way
to capture this pawn
f takes is pretty obviously bad because
you lose a bishop and get forked
in h takes it turns out to also be bad
because you have induced another
weakness in the structure and now of
course knight takes e6 is going to be
very strong when after takes we can come
in with the queen and recapture our pawn
and now all of a sudden it's it's white
with all the attacking opportunities
bishop h6 h5 h6 for example all sorts of
ideas uh just leap into the position now
that these light squares are so weak
however shock made a critical mistake
here um and that mistake was that black
does not have to capture this pawn uh
and this is a a pretty important idea to
look out for
so g5 g6 this exact idea might not be
the most common uh but this idea of
sacrificing a pawn in order to weaken
the structure is going to be really
really common
i want to say most commonly in these
structures white will have a pawn on e5
play the exact same idea e5 to e6
forcing the pawn on f7 to capture and
then once again jumping in to the newly
weakened g6 square really important idea
to keep in mind when you have these
sorts of attacking positions so g6
good idea but it turns out black has the
very very powerful idea of completely
ignoring it i'm just playing knight to
c6
and the reason why this is so strong
is even though
uh black horribly weakens the structure
by by capturing and it allows the white
queen to enter into the position by not
capturing it turns out you lose a pawn
with g takes h7 but after king to h8
you've lost a pawn but you have kept
your king's safety
so what's the difference well now after
takes on e6 takes on e6 we still try
something like queen to g6 for example
we simply don't have the the threats
that we were going to have uh before uh
white's pawn turns out to be a pretty
effective shield for for black's king it
sort of stays in front of the black king
and prevents the white pieces from
really activating and attacking uh
attacking black's king and in the
meantime by the way black didn't do
nothing black developed a knight it's
gonna allow ideas like knight to e5 to
come in uh and black is going to be very
very active in the position now
compared to this other line that we
looked at with takes
takes and takes
by the way white doesn't even
necessarily have to capture right away
you can do something else even something
like h5
in this position
when again without this pawn shield on
h7 it's also going to act as an inroad
for for white's pieces
so instructive stuff here uh g6 powerful
attacking idea but a nice defensive idea
in response by scpenko he allows shock
to capture his pawn and then uses
white's remaining pawn as a shield
really cool attacking and defensive
ideas
we now see queen to b3 by shock which is
the right idea but a couple moves too
late it was much stronger when black was
undeveloped with the knight on b8 and
now uh asipenko once again uh misses his
chance to fully seize uh
the lead here he plays the natural move
queen to d7 sort of mentioned this move
in the other line
but in this instance black does have uh
a better option and that has to do with
the downside to playing g6 and g takes
h7 whenever you move a pawn forward even
if your pawn is as far as far as as far
advanced as the one on g5 uh whenever
you continue to move it forward it
creates weaknesses
in this case the pawn on g5 did a nice
job of stunting these dark squared
pieces for black and now that it is
moved and captured on h7 uh it becomes
relevant because black can actually take
on h4 and this was the the complicated
way for escopenko to to seize the lead
once again
white could take on d5
but now we have this nice move bishop g5
in response with
threats on this diagonal and once again
we're not so worried about opening up
the h file because this pawn on h7 is
essentially working for black again
great defensive idea allowing this pawn
to live
just as an example line something like
takes on e6 takes an f4 these are the
complicated tactics that that would give
scpenko
an advantage here following up with
queen to d7 and if we do a quick
metallic count of the material uh both
sides have five pawns uh but one of
white's pawns is on h7 and black has
this great uh control great hold over
the center and it turns out that white's
king is the one that that has to be
worried again it's pundit h7 working for
black and in any end game it's
immediately going to be captured
um so bishop takes h4 uh turns out to be
the way to get the lead now there are a
couple of reasons why essay punko might
have not done this number one it is
still kind of scary to open up the h
file maybe he was also worried about
ideas like queen takes b7 uh when it
turns out this move knight e5 is the
only way for black to keep the lead um
but uh complicated stuff but bishop h4
would have would have seized the lead
instead after queen to d7 we're just
going to get some simplifications take
on d5
and now the queens get traded off and a
lot of the intrigue in the game turns
out to be lost here shock had this nice
attacking idea pushed the pawns forward
on the king's side but when it started
to started to fail he realized he needed
to bail out get his pawn back in the
center of the board and simplify things
just a little bit
now with queens off the board the
character of the game is gonna change a
little bit no longer are we gonna see uh
much hope of checkmating black early on
or much danger of white's king sitting
on f1 to get checkmated instead both
players are just going to simply
activate their pieces work to c1 uh king
h7
knight to d3 notably by the way black
captures this pawn after the queens are
off the board with queens on that would
be risky queen's off it's just a free
pawn
uh we get knight to d3 bishop out to f4
and again both sides just activating
rook to g1 f3 bishop f2
f6
and i believe
um yeah maybe after bishop f2 the
players actually just agreed to a draw
here which is a little bit early i think
there was still a lot of chess left to
be played uh but i went through some
example lines and it turns out there's
just not much going on in this position
uh for example if f6 something like a3
a6 white can activate the rooks try to
pressure this pawn on d4 but it doesn't
ever lead to much uh we just see
something like bishop b7 and here
already
now the computer starts just shuffling
the pieces and saying the position is
drawn just for example though something
like king g8 b4 king f8 bishop g3 we can
even see some simplifications when
you're just ending up in a drawn rook
end game so the players agreed to a draw
after all of this craziness in the
opening after everything turns out if
neither player makes any huge mistakes
then the game is a draw now in this case
both players made a lot of mistakes
because the position was so crazy and
unusual
but
they tended to balance out in this
instance uh whenever white gave black an
opportunity black sort of played safe uh
and
allowed white to stay in the game
so that was a lot to go over so
questions on the actual game line uh
before i go back sort of do a quick
review of everything we talked about uh
anything stick out that you wanted to
ask about
okay fair enough so
let's go through the game one more time
and and talk about the important ideas
we started here
when again knight to c3 or knight f3
would have been normal instead we get g4
and again the idea is that if the knight
takes white is trying to play e4 give up
the pawn for time instead we saw scpenko
fall back on opening principles he was
unfamiliar with the opening and when
you're unfamiliar with the opening you
want to fall back on what you know which
is good simple chess moves we saw
white's idea continues with g5 trying to
get an advantage by harassing black's
pieces uh black follows this with knight
e4 bishop g2 bishop b4 check taking
advantage of the fact that white is
underdeveloped white plays this move
king to f1 uh in response we see bishop
back to e7 anticipating ideas like queen
to b3 and just trying to simplify things
white defends the pawn black again
simple chess castles we get knight h3
keeping pressure up here
c6 queen c2
and then again
black has this nice idea keeping in mind
that we want to activate our bishop nice
idea of knight d6 instead essepenko
plays e5 much more direct but does allow
white back into the game and after this
knight to d2 keeps the pressure
we see simplifications
knight f4 bishop to e6 once again we
have a quality if white plays something
like queen queen to b3 pressuring d5
instead nice attacking idea of g6 uh
trying to tempt black into weakening the
structure but black comes up with a nice
defensive idea of using the pawn as a
shield and then lastly we saw after
queen to b3 uh estipenko's last chance
was to snatch this pawn on h4 uh
entering some more tactical
complications instead queen to d7 we got
the trades on the d5 square the queens
came off and and the game simplified
so it takes 30 seconds to go through the
game when you talk about it like that
but again all these really complex
important ideas uh making an appearance
in this game i absolutely loved this
game watching it live was was a thrill
um
so
let's go ahead and talk about it what
would have happened if scpenko captured
on g4 well i did a lot of analysis
and for those fans of playing crazy
openings like 3g for yourself the good
news is i am pretty sure that this move
does not lose by force if it did lose by
force the move that that would prove it
would be knight takes g4
uh so i did a lot of analysis and it
turns out it is quite tricky for both
sides there's a lot of different options
um and so if you are thinking about
playing 3g for yourself in this position
or you're thinking about snatching this
pawn in response we recommend you go
home do a lot of work and make sure
you're confident on the variations but
just to give you a taste uh e4 is going
to be the idea
and it might be rather tempting to play
this move queen h4 right away in
response you know activating this queen
defending the knight and threatening
checkmate but it turns out that white is
actually pretty well prepared to handle
this with the move queen to e2
uh and now things are going to get
really really complex for example bishop
to b4 check knight to d2 and now d5 is
surprisingly the the only move for black
to uh
sort of keep the balance
now why is that surprising well on the
surface it appears to lose a pawn
due to e takes d5
but it then it turns out that e takes d5
is not a good move for white because
black could castle
uh and after this
uh black is is simply going to recapture
on d5 and if white takes on e6 himself
you have to be rather nervous about what
you're doing to your king here on e1 so
so crazy stuff
uh so the short version is instead of e
takes d5 white should just play knight
to f3 let's see black's queen move back
to h5
now a3 bishop e7 rook g1 and kingside
castles again should be played but now
this is sort of the ideal version of
things for white turns out the position
is about objectively equal but look at
what white has going on now we have all
this pressure down the g file which did
open up in this instance against the
black king we've got three pawns in the
center of the board we've got an active
knight on e5 and black is certainly
going to have a lot of problems in this
variation
so i think this is sort of the dream
that shock mounted yara was was hoping
for and i think if people are going to
repeat this variation this is what they
want to see as well so
uh
three queen eight or yeah three or four
queen h4 while very very tempting
threatening mate defending the knight
does lead i think to favorable comp are
favorable complications for white the
position gets very very unclear very
muddy and white is going to be having
all the fun sort of attacking down the g
file
so instead of that it turns out that
very very surprisingly the move f5 uh
which
kind of made an appearance in the main
line uh turns out to be very very good
for uh black in this instance
um
basically a white because of playing g4
is not going to be having a comfortable
place for the king so white is not very
happy about taking on f5 and opening up
this file black is castling much more
quickly is able to attack in the center
much more easily and because of that
because of that the move f5 is just good
if you can't take on f5 it makes a lot
of sense so white plays knight to c3
and now we could consider doing queen h4
but i actually like this idea of knight
to c6 instead adding some pressure to
the center of the board
for example e takes f5 and only now
queen h4
what's the difference well the
difference is we have this pressure on
the center
we have the e-file opening up and we
have this queen being a little bit
overloaded we would love to play queen
e2 but because this knight is here now
knight takes d4 would come in so queen
to d2 has to be played instead which is
obviously a little bit awkward for the
white pieces and just as an example line
again bishop b4 is going to be a nice
idea
knight f3 for example queen f6 or g1
and actually queen takes f5
and after knight to h4 queen h5 bishop
to e2 for example
again just an example of how things
might go but things are wild and
complicated once again but it does turn
out black as ending up on the better
sided things for example queen takes h4
here rook takes on g4 queen back to f6
and compared to the other line it looks
as though white's pieces are a little
bit jumbled up a little bit misplaced
and black's king is going to be able to
castle and with this open f file now uh
have a lot of counter play against
white's king
so a couple example lines what it might
look like when it goes well for white
what it might look like when it goes
well for black uh either way knight
takes g4 if this is what you want to do
is gonna require a lot of work obviously
can go very very well can go very very
badly i think objectively black should
be doing doing pretty well with just
capturing the pawn
okay
so again any final questions on this
position or or this game it was a wild
one
took a lot a lot of time to cover it's
pretty pretty dense game
any final questions
okay
awesome in this case
uh i
in that case i want to talk about uh the
other variation that i was talking about
and look at this a little bit so
uh it wouldn't be fair to go over shock
mom yara's game uh with three g4 without
again
shouting out simon williams who's been
doing this garbage for years um he plays
g4 knight f6 and g4 in this position and
he's done this i think numerous times
throughout his career uh
and
it's very on brand for simon williams if
you haven't seen the ginger gm here in
person i think online a lot more people
know him uh check him out he's very
entertaining to watch
um so g4 and in this case simon williams
does not quite get the same respect that
shock mom and darv gets and his
opponents just capture that pawn for
free because why not uh and so let's
take a look at how this might go we see
e4 in this game d5 by black defending
this knight
bishop e2
increasing the pressure now and black
actually comes up with h5 in this
instance so kind of a similar idea to f5
just cementing this knight here and
going for counter play in the center
after e takes d5 queen takes d5 was
played
we saw knight to f3
and then in the game black didn't play
quite the most accurately think
something like bishop f5 and it's
already pretty clear that black got the
better side of things in in this opening
and because of games like this i think
this is why shock chose the third move
to play g4 rather than the second i
think
two g4 is pretty clearly just a much
worse version of this idea which is why
it's surprising that it's been seen so
many more times
instead though black played this weird
looking move c6 i don't really
understand what the idea was uh but
that's what he came up with just sort of
uh fixing the pawn structure a little
bit more defending the d5 square we saw
knight to c3 queen to a5 bishop to c4
bishop f5
bishop to d2 and now e6 and the game is
starting to look a little bit more
normal it's just that white is down a g
pawn sort of for no reason
uh queen to e2 was played queen to d8s
and queen side castles
and this is what i would call a good
version of this for white
black has wasted some time
moving in a triangle with the queen
uh wasted some more time playing moves
like c6 and rather than going for it for
quick development and because of all
that uh white is is gonna be doing
pretty well here uh bishop to e7 was
played in the game
and i'll just show you what kind of
happens we get rook to g1
g6 bishop to f4 simon williams slowly
but surely advances the pieces forward
knight to d7 and then white comes up
with this nice idea of playing d5 the
point being that after c takes d
bishop takes d5 is simon's idea when
after takes stuff like knight takes is
going to be
a little bit scary for for black to
handle and in fact just simply winning
winning for white so after bishop takes
black again cannot capture this piece
said plays rook to c8 and after bishop
to b3 the game starts to slip from
simon's grasp he had to keep the
pressure up play something like knight
to d4 and keep attacking in the center
otherwise at the end of the day white is
just down a pawn and that's sort of what
we see happen here with the extra pawn
on the king's side black's structure is
going to be very very solid and in the
meantime this white king on the queen
side can be attacked with this nice
exchange sack we saw queen to a5 in the
game
pressuring these dark squares king to b1
and simply now knight to f6 and it turns
out having an extra pawn is not just
something you can like say
i'm upon i'm going to win the end game
sometimes the extra pawn is very very
useful and and that's the case in this
position it just helps black's structure
sort of stick together makes it very
difficult to attack the black king
meanwhile the white king is is totally
exposed and that's essentially what
happens in this game um knight to e5 was
played again it turns out knight to d4
was white's best idea pressuring this
this light squared bishop after knight
to e5 the things very very quickly fell
apart for for simon we see knight to e4
with pretty major threats queen to c4
and now knight to c5 the black piece is
just very very quickly invaded on the
queen side and it turned into disaster
very weird move by simon knight to d7
trying to mix things up but black simply
takes on c3 with check
plays b5 and this queen
i believe is essentially trapped here if
you play something like queen to d4
you're gonna get this piece taken with
check and this piece taken with
checkmate
not ideal so simon sacrifices this queen
but obviously this is not going to work
out and pretty quickly later he ends up
just resigning knight d5 and resigns
so if that's the type of chess game
you're interested in playing you can
look at these lines two g4 three g4
lines where both players are just going
to be messing up all the time because
it's incredibly complex
but once again
if you're unsure of what's going on if
you're not sure of what to do you can
always take the essepenko approach and
just play simple chess just develop your
pieces uh control the center of the
board and your position is going to be
fine and in fact estipenko had multiple
opportunities to take the advantage in
his game all the while he incurred very
little risk so that's my advice for you
guys uh and again uh i don't think g4
loses uh on move three on move two might
be losing but move three seems like it
might actually be okay so
uh if you wanna play something like this
it just takes a lot of work
uh with that i think i'm gonna wrap it
up for the night so thank you all so
much for joining me we do have grand
master thomas kolev coming in right
after me for the next lecture insane in
the end game which is uh maybe going to
be just as insane as g4 on move three
we'll find out
as always my name is caleb denby thank
you all so much for coming out and i
will see you next time
[Music]
you